I think it's amazing you know I usually
say to people I have lots of friends I
get them to line up to make me look
popular but it is i'm in the story of
Boba Fett I think when they rerelease
the films in 96 suddenly there was a new
audience and they were beginning say
who's this character very little to do
but it was all his shadowy he's moving
all the time but very slowly but he's
dangerous and people like that kids love
it I mean side of the 35 year olds who
say cardio you're so cool but they don't
want to tell anyone else sit there that
your uncle and then you have the little
five-year-old you know Boba Fett's and
it have these big huge helmets they buy
it is extraordinary last last ten years
or so being invited everywhere around
the world
do you ever think when you signed on to
play preferred it would be like this no
I didn't think it was going to be like
this I feel they might say would you
come and open our school maybe to that
length and you sit there signing for a
while and chatty and give a speech or
something but not not to this I mean to
look around here
is a giant people from all over Europe
as well what do you think it is about
the star wars universe it's been so
popular and soba loves all over the
years Star Wars is Billy it's a science
fiction film is like the big tall darth
vader princess leia the prince you know
Darryl Harrison Ford it's an old story
told in space and I think it's
nonviolent I know that sounds funny when
you see a sort of bloody arm in the last
one revenge of the city but it's pretend
liners the kids have said I'm going to
be strong baby and you're going to be
Boba Fett okay it's I did that
pretending to ride a horse because I
remember the Cisco Kid and The Lone
Ranger shows how old I am but that
that's what it's about it's a fun fun
film and people you can see so many
people here dressed up of course you've
got storm was coming back for three more
episodes JJ Abrams director at least the
first one what do you think about it
coming back and what kind of direct do
you think JJ Abrams are made it's not
about to me is very nice of you to say
what about coming back if
if it happened it would be it would be
great but if it doesn't happen i'm not
going to be upset because during the
original three i think that that was
something but i'd love to be involved in
some some way you know just maybe
walking past the camera like this you
just drift away just being cool them i
say that's the guy we want you never
know we'd love to see that happen we
would have made that happen I think Boba
Fett's got to have a comeback yeah but
the best thing you know you have this
possible problem the Boba Fett is there
and he's being cool and they still away
and if you're sitting there with the
helmet off they'll go hang on a second
wait a minute always him and people in
the audience won't be listening to
what's going on in the film
so it's best to wait to see but thanks
for asking for me I mean what do you
think cuz it's been talked old Harrison
Ford and Mark Hamill and of course
Carrie Fisher as well making a comeback
the future episodes what you think about
that I think it's fantastic yeah when
they've all got to try and look younger
I always thought maybe I mean they look
pretty good but she's you'd have the
body and then just have a paint shop to
facing maybe they can do that with
technology and with me don't need it
because I'm wearing helmets yeah what
was it like wearing out unbearable I
mean people say what was the costume
like unbearable and this just so heavy
and you were sweating all the time but I
was Boba Fett I had to stand strong and
be cool
you